hey welcome to what is called comedy
comma Sato TV that's al Jackson Marquez
behind the camera
Tony trim somewhere else we're one show
in and it's been lots of regrets already
one of them being the place that we ate
yesterday lambs Creek and Mansfield
Pennsylvania hey the rest of us a real
piece of [ __ ]
let me tell you about the service took a
while there's only three other tables
there the fuss was going on that lambs
Creek and then order wings yeah I know
slightly stereotypical was so what I get
the wings
everybody likes wings I get the wings
they bring celery they bring one
long-ass celery stop the [ __ ] was that
last Creek think I'm just about to sit
by not the same celery together well one
of us go [ __ ] a celery on some all dogs
go to heaven that [ __ ] no man that's
just bad service and then we brought up
the celery to hers you said you want a
knife no huh yeah I would like a knife
trying to stab you in the throat with it
you hit consider it but good waitress
what's wrong with you
I wouldn't stab you in the throat over
the celery situation but hypothetically
in a world in a video game world where
everybody gets to just come back from
dying
we live in a video game world for no
consequences and people can just die
come back you just wake up your
character just wakes up at the hospital
[ __ ] with all your money and weapons
gone I would have stabbed you the neck
hurt you whatever should never see this
then what else about the service it took
very long wasn't a good restaurant to
buy abs were bad
that was just real real horrible
experience lambs Creek put in some
pictures here pictures of lambs Creek
pictures of people sad it's other stuff
other images
what other images could I think of that
will make me maybe a baby there just got
some candy taken from it that's more in
line with lambs great vibe just a bad
place we're back here eating dice pipe
pineapples Rick Ross wrapped about these
don't know why wrapped about this [ __ ]
is like 5 bucks is good but
so that is our review of lambs Creek so
if you out there on the road I would not
recommend lambs Creek in Mansfield
Pennsylvania